[inaudible].
All right,
so we've been talking a bit about the tech component of this grand cultural war
that's going on.
You guys cool that you're,
you're a small company or you're funded on Patrion which were funded on Pedro
and it's pretty awesome.
You have people that voluntarily pay you to support your content and make you
grow.
I know how validating and rewarding it is and all that stuff,
but you find yourself often up against the big boys,
right?
Like bots funded to a hundreds of millions of dollars by different things and
you're being critical of them here.
Yeah.
So it does get me to back to something that I started with before about where
does it come from for,
for you to just be brave.
I don't want to,
I don't want to belittle that part of it that there's a new internet developing
and I think is people that are doing this sort of thing.
It's not these well funded,
well oil machines that we're watching them crumble.
You know,
I just,
you sent me this morning,
this thing about boxes ad rev is off by 15% or something and it's like we've got
slim trim companies and I think I really believe that's the future economically
of this.
Yep.
As well as in terms of protecting the ideas.
Yeah.
So we,
uh,
a pretty,
we have a pretty amazing story.
Um,
we,
um,
I started by myself and I ran the website for maybe a year or even a year and a
half before I got my,
um,
assistant editor on board who's now sort of the managing editor and he's
extraordinarily talented,
extremely hardworking.
So I'm very indebted to him for all of that.
Jonathan,
Hey,
I'm in my other editor,
Jamie.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's give credit where credit's yeah.
And,
um,
am I contribute,
is that all so amazing?
Yeah,
but we,
I hate now as of 20,
uh,
2018 September,
we're getting up to 1 million unique visitors a month with a staff of all part
time staff of six or the six or seven people.
And we are getting almost a million uniques a month.
I am aware of magazines that have a budget of millions of dollars.
Yeah.
That can not compete with our traffic and who have staffs of star,
like staffing capacity of 30 40,
50 people.
So we're extremely lane but we're hardworking.
Uh,
and we're nimble and innovative.
Like I'm very,
I'm always thinking about innovations to the business model.
What can we do that's different?
I think just following in the footsteps of the old model is probably a recipe
for failure.
And I truly believe that advertising is on the way out.
I know people can still make some money through advertising,
but I think advert advertising gives you a vulnerability because now you see
these activists trying to like target brands if their brand is next to some
content that activists don't like.
So I think advertising is just,
I think it's Vaughn,
there's a vulnerability associated with it.
And
is it almost a fake vulnerability though?
Because I always think when,
you know,
they always try to boycott had it.
He,
for example,
and it's like all of the people trying to boycott him,
putting aside whatever he said on that given instance,
they don't watch him in the first place.
And yet the advertisers still feel that they have to bow to the mob.
And I always find that to be a strange thing.
Like there's very few people who like entity who are,
who are so shocked by something he said that they want to boycott it.
Yeah.
It's always people who hate him in the first ways that don't watch.
So there's an odd piece of this that's like slightly disconnected from reality,
I think.
Well,
Kay,
um,
corporations and companies in general are skiddish and conservative and they
want to protect their reputations and they,
they're afraid of,
um,
any kind of controversy.
And,
um,
I agree with you that the,
these activists on social media who are targeting companies,
they're a tiny,
tiny minority of the population.
Most people don't care or buy into this stuff,
but corporations is,
it's probably some PR person who's like,
Whoa,
we don't want any controversy.
Yeah,
let's detach ourselves.
Um,
but you know,
it,
that kind of,
um,
timidity and,
lack of strength and lack of spine is not something that is part of Colette.
So we very much conscious of if we ever get mobbed and we do get mobbed,
sometimes we don't apologize.
We don't,
we don't,
um,
we don't give into the heckler's veto basically.
Yeah.
And I,
I really think it's important for,
um,
uh,
corporations,
company leaders,
anyone in a leader's leadership position to grow as spawn in the era of social
media and to not take any of this outrage seriously.
Yeah.
Not Take it seriously or not take it.
I mean,
I think we sort of,
we have to take it seriously because it is sort of infecting a lot of society,
but maybe not take it as if it's necessarily right,
just because it's outrageous.
Is that fair?
Yeah.
I,
you can save the,
um,
recent example,
an editor of the New York review of books,
amber I met was fired because he published an article,
uh,
by Canadian radio journalists who was a credibly accused of many cases of sexual
assault.
And I think the radio journalists was like,
is um,
a bad dude,
but the editor was sacked for publishing his article within like the space of
two days or something.
So there was a social outrage phenomenon and it's all wrapped up with me too.
And then he's just fired just like that.
And it's like,
okay,
take some time out to consider it.
Like listen to the feedback from your readers or from people on social media,
but when did we start making decisions?
So suddenly these important decisions that affect people's livelihoods,
that's what I find,
um,
astonishing that people in leadership positions just sort of throw all caution
to the wind and just say,
okay,
we're going to sack someone because some people on Twitter on happy.
Yeah.
And also the guilt by association part of this,
right?
I mean it's,
it's possible for a slim trim operation that you have,
you might find out in 10 years,
you might try it out then one of the guys you're working with now,
three years ago did,
did something awful and then they'll use that to try to tar you and the danger
of that or that you sat down with somebody and now we can put out a chart that
links that person to this person.
Did that person,
this one.
Yeah.
We're in an age of the Internet within six steps.
You can lead anybody to Kevin Bacon or Barack Obama.
It's like,
it's,
it's pretty ridiculous.
Yeah.
And the guilt by association is e F or,
I mean it's a fallacy but it is powerful and we,
we do find ourselves tainted and it's tricky and I think we have to,
every situation we have to judge on a case by case basis.
Um,
and,
and you probably right,
it probably is going to happen,
but I trust my readers and um,
I,
I feel like they know who we are.
They know they're aware of our values and they can make the appropriate
judgments at the time.
Yeah.
So,
all right.
So even though we've spent most of the time here and,
and most of the things that you guys are writing,
talking about what sort of going on with the modern left and frustrations that
everyone knows that I have with these guys.
Yeah.
Um,
let's talk about the parts of their right that,
that you actually find a scary or untoward or whatever you want to call it.
What do you think the alt right is at this point?
Like if someone says,
you give me the definition of all right,
what does that even mean to you at this point?
Uh,
well,
I,
um,
consider them to be the white nationalists that uh,
that one in if ethno state and they,
they're pretty morally repugnant and that pretty scary.
And they engaged in some,
in quite vicious trolling a send death threats.
Um,
the journalist's Cathy young for example,
was one of the first people to write an article criticizing the bigotry of the
outright.
And she had,
um,
death threat called into her home.
And,
uh,
the,
they're pretty scary,
but I think there a small group.
Yeah.
How are we able to quantify that?
Because that's one of the things that like,
I think people are just very confused that they're making it.
See the media makes it seem,
because they call everyone all right or far right,
that there's this massive group,
I can only talk about this in a,
an American Lens,
but maybe,
maybe it's a little different Australia,
but that there's this massive group of white nationalists who are coming for,
to turn America into some sort of ethno state.
Now I'm not saying there aren't racist.
Of course there are racists and of course there are bad people and people using
these tactics,
but I believe it's just a tiny sliver.
And then,
and then on top of that,
you have both sort of the meme makers in the shit posters and the rest of them.
Yeah.
Those guys,
you may not like what they do,
but they're not there.
They're having fun in their eyes and a lot of ways they're not just the evil
racist.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think a mistake was made,
um,
back when Milo was around and I think he,
he started using the term alt right and he might not have been aware of where
that term originated and actually originated with the white nationalists.
And um,
you think Milo was using it more in the way that I just laid it out of just sort
of these shit posting me,
make something,
look without acknowledging the other people.
I don't know if he was aware of where the term originated on art,
but it was a huge era,
uh,
Arab for people who are just into,
um,
shit posting.
It was a huge area era for them to use that label for themselves because unless
you're,
what in my view,
unless you are a white nationalists,
you're not an,
you're not an all right.
It,
I mean they had,
they,
the,
the label I think came about in 2007 and they,
I think it was Richard Spencer who created the alt right journal or something.
So it was a big mistake for people who just want to have fun online and he wants
to,
um,
you know,
just like push back against some of these PC orthodoxies.
It was a huge mistake for them to use the term for themselves.
And that's given license now for critics to apply the term on everybody who,
who pushes back against PC dogmas.
Um,
and that's really unfortunate.
Yeah.
But you know,
we have to just say it over and over again.
Like these people are repugnant and we,
we don't want to have anything to do with their ideology.
The ideal is all ideologies authoritarian.
It's racist.
It's,
um,
an and they engage in very scary vicious behaviors.
Yeah.
So absolutely.
I will co-sign all of that.
Yes.
For the record,
of course,
this is a repugnant ideology and these people are racist and all those things.
So I'm less concerned about that because I do believe it's a small sliver that
doesn't have real institutional power.
Now,
maybe it's going to gains,
I mean,
I think there's evidence that at least in eastern Europe that some of these
ideas,
partly as a pushback to the immigrant immigration problems that maybe is gaining
some power.
Um,
but are you concerned that it has a bigger institutional power?
Because I think the stuff that we're often talking about is because we're
worried about institutional power and structural power,
not just that there were mean and bad people out there,
which yes,
there are many bad people out there and they will always be mean and bad people
out there.
Yeah.
Because my background is,
so recently in academia,
I focused a lot on universities and the ideologies that are popular within the
university.
So that makes me focus on,
um,
left wing ideologies such as critical theory,
poststructuralism and Marxism.
Um,
if I was in a different context,
I might focus more on right wing ideologies and the effect that they have on
institutions.
And I'm sure,
so you're given a little nod to the postmodern.
Is there,
because you're showing that your own bias is a little part of how you look at
yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah,
yeah,
I'm sure if I was closer to institutions that have more of a right wing
ideological influence,
so I would be criticizing that more criticizing those influences more.
Yeah.
Um,
being Australian is,
uh,
in Australia,
our,
our conservative or right wing ideologies are quite different to America.
So,
um,
you probably already know this,
but we have universal health care.
We have gun control,
we have a welfare state.
So if I lived in a country where we didn't have those things,
I would probably be advocating for the right.
Um,
but you know,
a lot of this is context specific and you criticize what,
you know,
sorry,
a part of the reason why I criticize the,
um,
what Jordan Peterson calls,
postmodern near Marxism is because I've experienced it.
I see it all of the time in academia,
in academia,
academic settings,
and,
um,
I worry about the impact of that,
that ideology is having on media,
the law,
um,
and just the broader culture.
Yeah.
Are you hopeful that some of the good ideas that we've talked about here are
going to win out?
That,
that seems to be one of the biggest questions I get at public events now.
Like I think there is a sense that we've woken up a certain amount of people.
You know,
this Peter's in tours selling out every theater.
Thousands and thousands of people literally all over the world will be in
February,
in Australia in February.
Yeah.
Um,
but I think there's still a concern of like how much worse cake yeah.
Before it gets better.
Yeah.
And that's a question people ask me as well.
And I the,
I mean,
I didn't have an oracle,
I can't see the future.
And all I can say is that I'm doing my very best to counter bad ideas and that
it's,
it's actually anybody who's concerned.
I mean,
they have some responsibility and I think everybody should think about sharing
the risk.
So,
you know,
when Charlie Abuse People truly,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
in Charlie Hebdo happened and the mainstream media in Europe and the UK and
America I think didn't want to publish that cartoon of Muhammad,
which got those men and women killed.
Douglas Murray came out and said,
do it shit.
The risks.
That's when I became aware of that.
That's one of his best moments is incredible.
It's on youtube.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
something that impacted me a lot as well.
And you know,
I,
it,
anyone who's concerned about the way our culture,
broader western culture is headed,
needs to think deeply about how they can make a little bit of difference by
sharing the risk.
Just speaking honestly in conversations with friends speaking honestly and
openly in the workplace,
normalizing conversations and um,
yeah,
just,
just taking on a little bit of race.
Yeah.
What does that tell you about the slide that has occurred in the West?
Is this just a,
um,
is it an infection of success or something that we could be so successful that
even taking a little risk seems awful to people?
Eh,
he humans,
ah,
very conformist and most people are,
it's unfortunately,
um,
and a lot of what we're talking about,
these bad ideas that are being promoted.
I only promoted by a tiny,
tiny minority of people,
but they're very noisy,
loud and aggressive.
And the problem is simply the silent majority not being feeling too intimidated
to sort of push back.
And if we can encourage those who are in the silent majority to push back
against it locks on both sides,
both the hard right and the hard left.
Um,
I think,
oh,
create a much healthier civil society.
Yeah.
But it's about empowering the moderates to speak freely,
speak openly and,
and,
and not feel afraid,
like ashamed of the moderate views.
Right.
They've also turned via words like civility and moderation or thought of as bad.
Now you're offensive or you,
you don't want to murder half the people,
you know,
you're not Thanos from Avengers.
You must be evil.
Yeah.
I mean
those people that people who are gay,
that civilities is a bad thing.
And um,
we see a lot of this now by the way,
that civility is a bad thing.
A lot of think pieces about this.
Well,
I would argue that some unrepresentative of the broader population,
I know that media and certain parts of media and universities have been captured
by cultists in a way,
and they have these crazy ideas.
But I would be careful about generalizing those ideas to the broader population
because I think most normal people are pretty chill.
Yeah.
I mean,
I haven't spent enough time in your country to to know,
no,
I,
I think you're right.
I mean,
I'm out there going across the country realizing that there are so many,
just decent good,
yeah.
People,
The hysterics and the way that I said earlier about how social media has leaked
into reality or something.
Yeah.
It's making everyone feel crazy,
but I am meeting these incredible people all over the country that they just
want to live and let live and yeah.
Maybe I don't know your feelings on abortion for example.
Maybe we agree.
Maybe we don't.
It just seems that actually seems irrelevant at the moment.
Yeah.
That that sort of says saying we touched on briefly right before we started that
politics,
I was saying how I'm not that interested in politics per se at the moment,
even though this is all framed within a political lens,
that I'm much more interested in culture.
Yeah.
Is that how you feel about this and is that always how you felt about this or
has something shifted?
Definitely.
I've never been particularly interested in partisan politics,
but I think that politics is downstream of culture,
so the ideas that are popular within a culture then get reflected in your
politics.
So if you want politics to be a certain way and to be a bit healthier and less
dysfunctional,
you want to impact the culture first because culture is bigger than politics.
Yeah.
Is there a danger that we're just in this like locked cultural war now so that
our politics can never get better?
Like we sort of have this othera authoritarian leftism and now we've got Trump.
These are,
these are the cultural fights that we're having now.
There's a couple of us in this spot,
right?
Yeah.
But like that it's all politics is going to come from those two things at the
moment.
Yeah.
Then politics sort of is almost irreparably damaged.
Look,
I don't know what the future holds for the United States.
From an outsider looking in it,
it does look quite scary that the level of tribalism,
that's,
that seems apparent.
Just the,
and the amount of hate and distrust that each side has for the other.
It's quite scary.
Um,
I just hope that if the worst happens to the United States,
we will always have,
we will have outposts where western civilization survives and thrives.
New Zealand,
Australia.
Yeah.
So basically going back to what I said at the beginning,
it's good to be surrounded by water.
Yeah.
We'll be,
we'll be an outpost and we'll pay the extra room in your house.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're going to keep,
yeah,
yeah.
A lot of people are going in New Zealand and buying houses there in case the
worst happens.
Oh God,
I don't want to end on this terrible.
We've got to bring this back.
All right.
So there's concern about that.
Yeah,
of course.
Like,
right.
If you want to go down that rabbit hole,
you could look at all of these ideas that I truly think are the ideas that could
unravel western society of free thought and all the things.
That's why I talk about them so much,
but there is a counter and then that's what we got to keep doing.
So bring the bring can bring it home on a positive note please.
Before people start buying real estate in New Zealand or you were just trying to
help the market in Australia there?
No,
no,
we don't need any help in the housing market.
We,
I'm optimistic because I see the amount,
the positive reception that I get through quizlet,
our audience grows every month.
Um,
more and more people are contributing to our website,
feeling brave enough to write their thoughts down and send it through.
And the thing is,
every individual has the power to change the world of ideas.
If you've got an idea and you can articulate it and write it down and send it in
or um,
articulated on in,
in some other fashion,
you do have the power to transform and impact this,
this culture,
and to make a huge difference.
So that's,
that's incredible.
And that makes me feel happy and optimistic.
All right.
That is how we can get,
we can't end it on the seasteading.
We're going to know what a world kind of thing for more on Claire's work.
Check Out colette.com and they are also on patriotic.
Okay.